foreign
for example now when
he said God should be Limitless
Limitless yeah in his Essence remaining
yeah the guy who speak about it next
week the guy said to him is golden tree
talking about God
when you turn into atheists for your day
above his creation
Allah said that and no one knows the
death of Allah and his name is
nonsense about this this composed of
parts and partless spaceless Timeless
all of these calamities of the column of
Alice and it's not the speech of the
cellophosale you know we describe Allah
describe himself
and the way of the the the the seller
the speech of this sort of closing
remarks
there's five in total
so Muhammad presented the language of
the deity of the botany is known as IBN
Cena
the necessarily existing being
by reproducing his series of arguments
that were designed to undermine and
poison the argument used by the
affirmers of the attributes in
particular those following the way of
even
this deity is immaterial incorpio which
is the slogan innovated into Islam by
Allah
and which was used to deny all of the
attributes it is a deity that is not
composed of Parts which is the argument
used by the multifelsifier and the
martezila to reject the attributes and
by the ashayana to reject the sifatal
khabariya then he threw all of his
inhalation and misguidance upon the
Quran the speech of Allah upon one of
the great swords of the Quran
in which the reality of tohit is
explained instead of the language of the
tall Hill The Messengers he explained it
through the language of the tawheed of
the jahmir and sifa from the misguided
wandering stress this same false futile
tohid which brought trials and turmoil
to the ummah so my brothers and sisters
that when people say why are you
splitting the ummah the normal I bless
you that the reason almost were divided
because of jebus of one
because of the
because of the khawaris before that you
know so the ummah will divide because of
Jamil and
because bring in Innovation misguidance
to the um
and the peoples are adopting those
misguided claimings from The Deen and
they start departing from the way from
so in reality who was causing splitting
the people of innovation misguidance the
people soon as they stick to the Quran
the Sun and do we have the salaf I say
no let us go back to the Aristotle and
so on even though they don't say it but
as they asked they go back to so we stop
inshallah
bless you all and then we have another
episode and also I thought I'll bring
this last uh
foreign
whosoever
from this ummah
upon other than guidance
and he thinks
that he is upon Guidance the truth
return them to the truth so that he may
be from the people of Truth so we ask
you know Allah to guide us
and guide Muhammad
is his religion this is not you know
it's not personal personal you don't owe
me money money yeah